58 people died the night of one october
but two more have since lost their fight
with wounds from the shooting
including one who died earlier this year
eight news now's hector mejia has gotten
to know samantha arjun
and her family and he shares her story
parents should never have to bury their
children for rudolph and savagery or
june
this is the grief that grips their heart
every day we were all there
and they took the respirator off and i
see my child didn't breathe anymore
three seconds and she was gone she's
gone
god forever their daughter samantha was
unable to recover from the bullet
that entered her leg during the one
october massacre one
mentally direct my shot my daughter
the bullet came out she had a plate from
under her knee to her ankle
but she had many fragments in there that
was causing
so much pain so much pain one year after
the shooting in 2018
samantha talked with us about her
recovery and going home in a wheelchair
good samaritans helped her escape the
gunfire that was raining on the route 91
harvest festival
the 49 year old loved country music but
above anything else
she was a devoted daughter and sister
her appearance was her life
and she was our life so it's basically
my best friend
she is basically hard to live right now
samantha's parents are finding some
peace by knowing she's no longer in pain
my child wherever you are
i bless you take care of yourself
all this remember your mommy and your
daddy look out for us please and your
brothers
all they can do now is visit their
daughter at the cemetery we'll go this
thursday
and take flowers for her
it's all i can do
hector mejia 8 news now while your heart
breaks for those parents samantha never
had the chance to meet the woman a
complete stranger who drove her to the
hospital the night of the shooting
she also didn't get to finish a book she
started writing about
everything that she went through